The joe rogan experience.
So that's the scene.
I actually,
uh,
you know,
and when I say where did you get this?
Uh,
Johnny Depp actually
hadn't lived a funny line.
He goes,
my dentist.
But
it was funny cause he's turns
out he's a very funny guy.
But I did say this when I was filming
that scene and it became in my standup,
I hate to be corny and do
a story from my standard,
but it is true.
I didn't really know
those guys at well at all.
And uh,
I go,
is anybody in this scene not on probation?
And Johnny Depp's like,
what did you do?
I go,
I said,
the tonight show I'm fired.
He's like,
yeah,
why did you do that?
I go,
I dunno.
I thought it was funny.
And then I'm like,
you smashed up that hotel.
He goes,
yeah,
I go,
were you drunk?
And Johnny Depp is funny.
He goes,
in my defense,
the hotel room made the first move
and this is a true story.
Cause then I look over at Paul Reubens
and he's just trying to ignore the
conversation.
It wasn't like,
Hey,
yeah,
I rubbed that is a weird
rock and roll thing,
the trash,
the hotel room and have
accountants pay for it all.
But I've always felt like during,
there was a period where I
was trashing television shows,
you know,
and,
and it was just,
I had the same kind of frustration
and rage and I thought,
well,
if I do it at a Holiday Inn,
you know,
big deal,
why don't I do it on a TV show?
That's kind of funny at least.
Yeah,
I know.
That makes no sense to you.
Looking at me
like the RCA victor
dog just staring at me.
I'm going to kind of see your point.
But I don't,
I mean,
I don't see the point
of doing hotel rooms.
I've never understood it.
He just smashing shit and like,
what are you doing?
That's just out of boredom.
But,
but it's so stupid to me,
just so child me,
I couldn't do that because I'd be
afraid of waking up people next door.
I'm serious.
Like I have no problems
sending the tonight fire or,
or,
yeah,
or smashing up the ice Sedenio hall show.
But the idea of,
I don't want to put
somebody else out to do,
you smashed Arsenio Hall shows too.
What did you do there?
Yeah.
Way crazier than the tonight show.
I,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause he got fired,
you know,
because of,
uh,
they put Chevy Chase on and
70 markets in front of them.
So paramount kind of fucked him over.
So I went out and I said,
are you really quitting?
Is like the week or two before?
And he goes,
yeah.
And I go,
well,
let's not make it easy on them,
you know,
so I spray painted paramount
sucks on the backdrop.
And then I,
uh,
I started throwing the couches into the
audience and the crowd was going crazy.
Oh.
And then I remember I took a television
set monitor and just threw it and then
put my,
uh,
put my work boots through the back of it,
Jesus Christ,
which is way more expensive than
anything I did on the tonight show.
But yeah.
So then they,
they like tell Arsenio,
like,
get him.
And so he wrestles me down and
as he's got me on the ground,
he goes,
thank you man.
Why?
Well,
because it's such a colossal fuck you.
And then like,
you know,
a week Jay had booked
me on a tonight show,
you know,
which,
and he came in the dressing
room and he's like,
you know,
don't,
don't smash up to more and stuff.
You know,
cause cause they were hoping
and I do something fucked up.
No,
I'm not blaming them.
I mean I wasn't asking that
was a bit of the green light.
Oh yeah.
I mean I knew that that was on
there to do something screwy but,
but uh,
you know,
what made it ours in was
that I actually had the,
the uh,
this uh,
lighter,
a barbecue,
lighter taped to my wrist.
Like I was like,
that's what made it arson.
Yeah.
Because it meant that it
was a predetermined yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
It was like a taxi driver,
you know,
the do you didn't worry about doing,
we worried was he did
that nobody was on fire.
No.
I mean,
cause I knew at Burton claim
and the lighter fluid and stuff.
And then I also had a buddy,
I said,
you know,
stand next to this fire extinguisher
if it gets out of control.
But,
but you know,
uh,
I,
I don't mean to make this my hook cause
I've talked about it on another podcast,
but,
but I guess it's good to clean,
clear the air,
you know?
Right.
But,
um,
I don't know.
People think like I was
banned from the tonight show,
but they had me on
immediately right after.
And it was,
it always weird.
It was weird,
was see is a lot bigger than
I always try to make Aiga.
That's it.
The little fire.
Jesus Christ.
Well that's cause I'm squirting
lighter fluid right there.
Why?
Why,
why did you do that?
I love that show to get ready.
And this is like speechless twice now.
He just looking at why
[inaudible]
ah.